estamos justamente a dos semanas del
inicio del mundial y hay varias
selecciones afectadas por una Plaga de
lesiones es el tema que vamos a analizar
con Sara Castro directora de deportes de
Caracol radio y del diario Vasco
Colombia o la Sara Qué tal Hola buenas
noches como siempre Un gusto vamos a
comenzar con Francia no estarán en este
mundial en crocante
dos piezas claves del centro del campo
en la conquista de Rusia 2018 barán y
Jules conden defensa son duda y Benzema
tiene unas molestias que lo han hecho
perderse Ya seis partidos de 13 en la
liga cómo afectan estas bajas y estas
dudas al juego de Francia a ver yo creo
que este es un caso muy interesante
Porque si bien hay bajas que han sido
definitivas en el funcionamiento general
del equipo yo creo que deseamos cuenta
con muchísimos recursos han salido
muchos jugadores jóvenes que pueden
llenar estas posiciones es el momento de
que jugadores como camavinga ha hecho
venir
esa Esa primera línea de volantes ahora
también es Claro que de Champions lo que
ha intentado es cambiar el sistema pasó
un 433 muy claro
intentan armar un 343 esto para darle
más solidez al medio campo ante la
ausencia de jugadores que llenaban muy
bien digamos Pogba era mucho más enlace
no En el sentido clásico de enganches
sino de intentar conectar las líneas y
cante que es un jugador que siempre
aparecía en todos los sectores del
terreno luego por el lado de la defensa
es que hice un listado de centrales y es
impresionante upamecano saliva
quimpembe vadiajil es decir hay muchos
jugadores para elegir ahora el tema de
si el tiempo da para lograr entrar en
una conexión importante que se necesita
siendo ellos los actuales y vigentes
campeones yo creo que se trata de una
transición bastante extraña para el
técnico de champs y que creo que va a
definir además su último campeonato del
mundo al frente de Esta generación lo
que sí tenemos claro es que Francia
tiene muchísimos jugadores jóvenes y un
futuro muy prometedor al margen de
Francia tenemos unas bajas sonadas en
Portugal por ejemplo el caso de Diego
llota y moverner con Alemania en
Inglaterra el caso el que se conoció
hace muy poco y de Ruiz James dos
laterales James que todavía es duda
otras elecciones grandes afectadas con
grandes nombres que están en duda o no
jugarían en Qatar Sí yo creo que una de
las más llamativos sala de Timo werner
porque él había vuelto a Alemania estaba
haciendo un muy buen trabajo y creo que
el 9 sí le puede afectar mucho al equipo
de flick porque porque tenemos un Müller
que estaba jugando mucho más Y
que ahora tendrá que tener un papel
fundamental es uno de los goleadores de
los mundiales Así que creo que es una de
las bajas más fuertes porque Alemania
sigue siendo inestable en este proyecto
de reconstrucción después de haber sido
campeones de Europa etcétera
los llevo yota también me parece que va
a ser complicado para Portugal porque es
uno de los socios naturales de Cristiano
Ronaldo y que en esa línea con con
Bernardo Silva con Bruno Fernández va a
ser mucha falta sin embargo esto le abre
la oportunidad a Rafael leao jugador que
está brillando en el Milan y yo creo que
estas son las condiciones o esas
momentos del juego que le permitan a
estos jóvenes llenar esos vacíos creo
que va a ser interesante lo que puedo
hacer el equipo de Fernando Santos ante
la ausencia de Diego gota y por el lado
de Inglaterra yo creo que los laterales
si bien cumplen tiene unas
características
muy importantes creo que ahí como
suplirlos porque los extremos son
importantes también en el juego de
Inglaterra hay muchos jugadores jóvenes
Así que veremos como como como este
Inglaterra que mostró muy mucho en la
Eurocopa puede empezar a digamos también
hacer favorito ya a nivel de un
Campeonato del mundo que tiene otras
características diferentes la
competencia a nivel latinoamericano hay
un caso particular el de Argentina
dybala es duda Di María apenas volvió
hoy y Messi ahora salió que tiene una
inflamación en el tendón de aquiles a
dos semanas para el mundial todo esto
afectaciones en la zona ofensiva de la
albiceleste yo no me preocuparía tanto
por la zona de ataque de Argentina creo
que lo de Messi Es simplemente
precaución justamente porque no creo que
quiera arriesgarse a tan pocos días del
mundial En cuanto la ausencia de Di
María bueno Di María hoy tuvo algunos
minutos y creo que es clave por esa
conexión que tiene con Messi no solo
desde el punto de vista del juego sino
también anímica y emocional pero creo
que de todas formas escalón y con Julián
Álvarez con Joaquín Correa con Ángel
Correa tiene algunas opciones también
para mover el ataque creo que la baja
que sería más sensible para paralelo en
el escalón y sería la de los chelso
porque con paredes y de Paul hicieron un
mediocampo que es base fundamental del
juego de Argentina no nos quedemos
solamente en la nota negativa hay muchos
jugadores que están brillando las
puertas del mundial Qué jugadores
destacamos por su momento de forma
actualmente Bueno lo del tridente del
París Saint Germain Yo creo que es súper
destacable lo que están haciendo mbappé
Neymar y Messi es fundamental pero no
solo como entra en el circuito de juego
y lo que están representando para el
París Saint Germain sino que entraron en
un nivel de disfrute de su juego que es
muy importante no solo juegan bien sino
que están digamos
guardando ese espíritu que es necesario
para liderar equipos y es disfrutar de
su juego lo que está haciendo Neymar Yo
creo que es la prueba máxima de que es
uno de los mejores sino el mejor jugador
del mundo en este momento y lo está
haciendo base de ese juego que en muchas
oportunidades perdió ante las críticas
mucha conversación alrededor de su
trabajo Yo creo que otro súper destacado
es Kevin de bruyne El mediocampista del
Manchester City y jugador de Bélgica va
a ser fundamental en este equipo es un
jugador que con Pep Guardiola ha ganado
muchísimo a su jugador con llegadas un
jugador con media distancia es un
jugador filtrador Yo creo que es uno de
los más destacados y en mi top entraría
también Federico Valverde lo que ha
hecho ancelotti con él es impresionante
está jugando como extremo va bien por
fuera arma bien por dentro es un jugador
que además Ahora tiene gol yo creo que
esos son mis jugadores top que llegan
como en un momento de forma fundamental
y que van a ser indispensables en sus
elecciones qué centro del campo el de
Uruguay que también está pasando por un
buen momento de forma además es un
Uruguay que ya va a jugar a otra cosa ya
dejó Esto del agarre que sigue siendo
parte de su esencia Pero creo que es un
es un equipo que elabora mucho más y que
va a tener otras características a la
hora de atacar